the upper demon moons are the strongest
demons in the world second only to demon
Daddy muzon and they are muzon's Elite
Fighting Force at rank number six we
originally had daki and yutaro a brother
and sister Duo who together formed one
powerful demon Moon after they were
defeated they were replaced by kaigaku a
demon Slayer who became a demon rank 5
belongs to Kyoko Rank 4 belonged to
hunting gu until he was replaced by
nakime at Rank 3 we have akaza possibly
the best villain in the entire series
Rank 2 belongs to dolma a cult leader
and probably the most effed up demon of
all finally rank 1 belongs to the
strongest demon Moon kokushibo he is the
brother of the strongest Demon Slayer in
history but he embraced the dark side
and became a demon subscribe to anime
uproar for more Demon Slayer videos